are you ready for it
are you ready for this today we are
swapping Mexican and American snacks one
of my face is mess up on some sappy tone
is there kind of like a chip or like a
pork rinds so they have like two lemon
and salt in Mexico I think most of the
snacks that I had where if it was candy
it was all spicy can you roll your R's
[Music]
the way I was brought up in my family
kandi was like sugar chili stuff like
that and chocolate was like its own
thing I'm a big fan in any context of
like sweet and spicy together alright
let's bring in the snacks you know
everyone in America knows her sister her
best friend her lover her tumblr
interests Nutella better we have a dip
that doesn't need a cookie to dip I
don't need to eat more than this because
it's a lot of actually you don't
actually give a lot this package she's
strong independent woman oh she don't
need no man but she doesn't I feel like
I've had these breadsticks and I've
definitely had Nutella so I get the gist
of it but this will actually be a first
for me when there was a pinata at a
birthday party you would snow that gets
fighting over candy and then ask it's
start to leave the area where the candy
was dropped you would notice these I
feel left on the floor like micing or is
it like pudding it's like Isis I think
this is like you want to eat chocolate
but you want to look like a grown-up and
be like I'm not getting candy I'm not
buying a snicker that's my power are you
ready yeah let's do it
you got to do often at the same time
okay there's just one
very nice
well done I like it looks like a
frosting
yeah it's literally frosting this is
exactly what I thought was gonna be very
Nutella eat what they're cooking this is
good like I'm definitely sad sighs oh
this doesn't taste bad
what about when I'd rather do you know
even breadsticks best of both worlds
that might be better
that's an upgrade yeah I mean I was at
the bat I mean Mexico knows how to do it
we know how to keep our kids pain and
love sugar I love them told you but this
is something you drink with like a shot
and you ready for the club
you're like anonymous like the top now
we're gonna try the next snack
this is airheads this is American
classic this is the best flavor of
airheads here we have bullfighting
though I always have this at my house
right you buy them by the pack and I
also believe they are like three
ingredients I have a bar of sticky sugar
the mystery flavor the white mystery
flavor was always like the cool one to
get just like you could wrap it's a
weird because it's sweet insulting yeah
and hot
[Music]
I don't I guess might as much that's
like spicy candy this reminds me of the
slushy the blue slushie it tastes like
something I would smell in like an attic
I like your heads I can have like two
airhead stops I could have seven of
those though this was like a basement
party going on in my mouth but the thing
with the airheads that I always hated
was it always get stuck in your teeth no
I think any perfect I'll take that right
sometimes you know what you grew up with
is what you like yeah I was just like a
parent you know this is good and I
really like this but I mean I'm eating
the whole thing bring on the next Matt
Goss we have mass abundance it's
literally what it says peanut candy
marzipan style as soon as you unwrap it
it kind of dissolves Oh like it doesn't
stay whole it's essentially blended
peanuts I will say oatmeal cream pie is
one of my all-time favorite snacks
regardless I he's like crazy growing up
it's like when you think you're gonna
get a chocolate chip cookie and you get
a raisin oatmeal that's what I think
this is my child
Debra the little Debra she stayed on
live she had zebra cakes she had opening
pies oh it didn't break what yeah yeah
how does that feel do another one
I'm not gonna eat it but just already
open oh you just won't open please fall
apart I hope the oatmeal cream pies
falls apart well I think this candy has
evolved actually I wouldn't see these at
Walmart all the time yeah is in the for
sale aisle if nobody ate that she was
cheap because she's for the community Oh
[Music]
like a loch deep I really do
Oh see how it just kind of crumbles it's
good oh it looks cute
I'm dr. Leale Debbie the filling is
outstanding these are good I I very much
like these not disappointed I never
never had the Metro Lisa for me I'm
always gonna have an emotional
attachment so middle green pies I agree
Wow wait you picked the cream on me Wow
no one ever my favorite yes these are
good but I still that's my number one
snack you know I'm gonna have to go with
the Dellacroce yes my BAE is watching
this right now this was a drug for me
and my sisters they do under deliver a
little bit like the commercials were
always like wow gosh watch out for the
tidal wave I love the gush in my mouth I
love turning into a crazy head of gush
kid here we have salad ethos this
specific flavor is your basic salad eat
only Mon and son there's different types
of versions of this this is the worst
one they look like old turns
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
how much is the sodium thousand three
hundred it's good for you
no wait what try to little bit longer
Wow Brandon
[Music]
there is a good version of these that
comes with the sauce and it's sweet oh
let's do it again we'll do it together
come on
[Music]
oh yeah now we're gonna go to the
gushers yeah I would like some of them
Oh
oh I wish I never had one of these
before and it does gush in your mouth
oh no I feel about gushing in my mouth
not used to that it's gonna happen I
trade you a pleasant swap will swap back
Oh ma'am it's so weird to eat a candy
that doesn't make my mouth feel like
it's on fire yeah but this probably
gives you cancer
she's so genetic this is nothing there's
a salt I would take the gushers for sure
though I would be very interested to try
the other version of of these in this
particular situation I would also pick
the gushers again these are not that
good but there is another version of
these that's really good you know what I
take it back no no for the gush and
everybody know I love this managements
but don't bring that too much I haven't
had these in a very long time now I know
why it really felt like it was from
Mexico like a childhood Mexico I thought
the Mexican snacks were very good with
my with one exception the American
snacks were pretty good they were sweet
they're sweet at the end of the day I
can't wait to eat more snacks and I
can't wait to get a little bit you some
cookie like let's go though even though
I probably preferred the American snacks
overall I do feel like the Mexican
snacks were like more ambitious and more
like nuanced in their flavors like they
were trying for something more
interesting than just like sugar and I
respect that
[Music]